Ukrainian officials say its forces have
made gains on the battlefield just hours
after President Vladimir zielinski
confirmed an expected counter-offensive
is underway there are reports of intense
fighting near the devastated city of
bakmud as well as in criminal in
Southwestern Donetsk Russian President
Vladimir Putin says Ukraine has failed
to advance anywhere on the front lines
meanwhile as defense minister has signed
an order which gives military volunteers
the same legal status as regular army
units fighting in Ukraine
Ukraine's military is expected to use
new tactics as fighting increases child
traffords in comatosk in eastern Ukraine
we spent this morning with Ukrainian
forces in the town of chassis of Yara is
important because it is the the first
town west of bakmut of course bakmut was
claimed by the Russians to be fully
under their control last month that's
something that's disputed by Ukrainian
forces but what we saw in that area
seem to be an effort by Ukrainian
artillery units to try as the military
call it softening up Targets in and
around bakmut that's basically testing
Russian defenses testing how strong they
are before a more Consolidated push
according to the ukrainians in that area
they said that they are making gains
slow gains from the south of Bahamut
heading around to the east of the town
they said that those gains could be up
to a kilometer a week but they admitted
that Sundays it could be as little as
say 20 meters and others 500 they also
said that there was a similar operation
happening to the north of bakmut as well
again just probing attacks it's very
difficult to say whether this in fact is
part of some sort of diversionary tactic
by the ukrainians to attract attention
away from another area where we're also
hearing that there is ongoing shelling
and heavy fighting that's south of
zaparizia but for all intents and
purposes the kind of operations that are
happening that's another siren that you
hear there in in the background here in
Crematory these Sirens are now going off
I suppose every hour or so
but as I say it's impossible really to
know for sure whether what we saw in
chass if you are close to bakmut was
anything more than a diversion from
potentially a bigger move being planned
by the ukrainians in other areas along
the front line Charles Strafford Al
Jazeera crematorsk
Michael mulroy is a former U.S Deputy
assistant Secretary of Defense and he
explains the planning that's probably
gone into Ukraine's counter-offensive
I think this is what uh we should have
actually expected uh they did shaping
operations Behind Enemy Lines collecting
intelligence so that they could then uh
do what's called a reconnaissance by
force where they probe the lines they
try to push in to find out where the
Russians are weak and where they are
strong and then they adjust their
campaign plans uh based on those uh
probes and I think that's what we're
seeing now so when the Russians say they
were they're repelling I don't think
that's accurate I think that is the
intent of the Ukrainian operations they
will send in an armored Force to see
where the resistance is strongest and
where it is weakest and then they will
calculate uh their campaign plan uh
based on those probes I think the
ukrainians essentially have had to uh
you know build the plane while they're
flying in the sense that they are in the
middle of an existential fight for their
country uh yet they're having to train
their forces on new weapon systems new
aircraft and new vehicles and so they
had to be able to do that so they could
effectively use those weapon systems in
this counter-offensive and I think
that's probably why you saw a delay but
I also don't think they want to rush
into anything they want to to do what's
most advantageous to them so that they
can take back as much territory as they
can and hopefully put Russia in a
position where they feel like they have
to come to some kind of negotiation or
hopefully they they decide that they
need to leave the country but I don't
think anybody expects that to happen
meanwhile Russia's foreign monasteries
criticized a U.N court of justice
decision to let 32 countries take part
in a genocide trial against Moscow the
ministry says each of them supports
Ukraine Kiev accuses Moscow of genocide
in the current conflict and it says
Moscow misused the international
genocide convention to falsely justify
its invasion of Ukraine last year Russia
says the court is abusing its power and
is threatening a peaceful resolution of
the conflict